Now let's move on to model
two where we're going to
build out a decision tree.
A decision tree algorithm is quite
different than the logistic
modelling algorithm.
This algorithm analyzes the data as
if it was a series of decisions.
This results in a comparison between
each of the different possible outcomes.
In order to illustrate the algorithm,
let's use a simple example.
I have a full basket of 120
M&amp;M's at a dinner party.
At the end of the night,
some have been eaten, and some have not.
I want to know if I can predict
whether a specific M&amp;M will get eaten.
Let's get started with only
one predictor variable, color.
This split would be chosen because
it would produce the largest
difference in percent eaten
between the two groups.
Okay, so
let's add a second variable, flavor.
The only possible split is with or
without peanuts.
With peanuts is 75% eaten,
without peanuts is 13.3% eaten.
Now if we compare that to color
which split would happen first,
color or flavor?
Since the flavor has a larger gap,
then flavor would cause the first split.
Once the first split has happened, each
split is treated completely separately.
So in order to do the second split,
we need to have the full
picture of the data.
Now let's only consider the peanut
groups for the second split and
the regular group separately.
So, how would be use the tree
to predict an actual result?
So let's say I'm a blue peanut M&amp;M, what
is the chance I'm going to get eaten?
If we trace along the path for
a blue peanut M&amp;M we can see that at
the terminal node there is
90% chance of being eaten.
And that's the general
gist of decision tree.